hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe auch heute wieder ein richtig
tolles rezept für euch und zwar gibt es
einen pot gericht das heißt ein rezept
auf einer panne oder einem topf und zwar
es ist heute etwas orientalisch aber
auch mediterran es gibt nimmt die pfanne
mit frühlingszwiebeln gramm hackfleisch
und kichererbsen und kichererbsen habe
ich glaube ich bisher nur in meinem
humus video mal verwendet ich finde es
aber sehr lecker und ja ich zeigen dass
die zutaten die wir dafür benötigen
ich habe hier 300 gramm nudeln vier
frühlingszwiebeln 4 knoblauchzehen 300 g
lammfleisch 600 milliliter wasser
hier habe ich noch kichererbsen bereits
ab gekochte die gibt es in der dose
fertig zu kaufen
das sind 400 gramm gewesen und 240 gramm
gewicht 2 esslöffel balsamico-essig ich
brauche olivenöl salz pfeffer und vorne
habe ich auch chili und kreuzkümmel bei
dem kichererbsen ist es so ihr könnt
natürlich auch die trockenen nehmen und
sie dann selbst abkochen
ich mache das nie selber ich finde bei
mir lohnt sich das nicht so ganz ich
brauche immer nur eine ganz kleine menge
und ich hab auch keine schnellkochtopf
also meine mama die macht das immer im
schnellkochtopf legt sie abends ins
wasser und am nächsten tag kurz zu kurz
auf das geht dann auch ganz schnell
aber für mich ist es eben praktischer
wenn ich sie direkt vorgegart aus der
dose nehmen jetzt nämlich das
lammfleisch
da könnt ihr natürlich auch ein anderes
fleisch verwenden ich mach jetzt fly
strauß das heißt ihr könnt auch direkten
lammfleisch benutzen
aber so kann ich einfach immer selber
bestimmen welchen teil vom fleisch ich
möchte und vor allem wieder fettgehalt
sein soll und lamm hackfleisch zu finden
finde ich auch gar nicht so einfach muss
ich ehrlich sagen
so muss das fleisch erst mal in große
stücke schneiden
und wer kein lamm möchte kann ich zum
beispiel auch einfach rindfleisch nehmen
das ist am etwas geschmacksneutral aber
ich finde ganz lecker vor allem mit gut
gewürzt ist
hier oben ist ganz wichtig dass ihr das
fleisch nicht reinstopfen sondern rein
fallen lassen und die spirale fleisch
selber holen kann ich so groß heute
und wenn man den fleischwolf jetzt
sauber machen möchte kann man einfach
oben noch brötchen mit rein geben dann
geht nämlich das restliche fleisch und
noch mit raus und darüber dass nicht
wegschmeißen
es kann man jemanden geben denn und hat
nein dem rat bekommt mit
man kann übrigens dieses brötchen jetzt
auch weiter verwenden wenn man zum
beispiel frikadellen macht da mag es
auch oft so dass ich dann soll auch die
zwiebeln gleich noch mit durchgehender
nämlich auch gleich zerkleinert und das
fleisch wird einfach mit herausgewaschen
sozusagen und bei der politik geht es
eben genauso als nächstes schneide ich
jetzt die knoblauchzehen und die
frühlingszwiebeln kinder klein und es
schneidet red habe ich jetzt dafür noch
mal gewaschen hatte da hatte ich vorher
das fleisch geschnitten
jetzt habe ich nochmal gespült damit ich
es das gemüse darauf schneiden die
knoblauchzehen die schneidig ist aber
ganz fein
die fries wiebel schneider jetzt in
dünne scheiben und zwei davon kommt
direkt mit in den topf und zwei davon
gebe ich erst später mit dazu
jetzt gebe ich das oliven pfannen so
etwa zwei esslöffel die pfanne ist jetzt
auch schon heiß und da gebe ich jetzt
schon mal die hälfte der tag fleisch mit
hackfleisch mit dazu ich warte jetzt auf
zwei mal an
seit ich den ersten teil schon mal um
nötig film nutzt muss muss laut leise
sei
falsches angebraten und jetzt hab ich
das auch rausgenommen und kann jetzt
hier nochmal knoblauchzehe und die
frühlingszwiebel anbraten
aber wie gesagt nur einen teil die
restlichen frühlingszwiebeln hinauf für
die garnitur brate ich dass etwa zwei
minuten an
jetzt kommt das fleisch wird damit dazu
und auch direkt die anderen zutaten also
auch die nudeln
sie kommen jetzt womit ein typischer
erzen und auch das wasser
und an der stelle gebe ich jetzt auch
schon den balsamico essig mit dazu das
lorbeerblatt und rosmarin den habe ich
den roman habe ich noch auf der terrasse
habe ich mir kurz abgezockt sein etwas
chili da gibt da einfach so viel rein
wir gerne möchte wenn es gern etwas
schärfer habt gebt ihr etwas mehr chili
mit rein und kreuzkümmel also kommen so
einen halben teelöffel jetzt kommt der
deckel drauf und so baldauf guckt werde
ich einmal durchführen und dann etwa
alle fünf minuten nochmal rühren das
dauert also insgesamt neun bis dreizehn
minuten je nach dem eben was für eine
nudel sollte ihr habt die sollten eben
schön bissfest sein und ja dann im
prinzip fast schon fertig also ein sehr
schnelles rezept
zwischendurch könnte jetzt das gericht
gerne auch würzen mit salz und pfeffer
und ich werde dann auf die zwischenzeit
nutzen um bereits den gurt vorzubereiten
denn wer das ganze mit joko installieren
bei steuerlichen ursprünglich herkommt
von glos aus dem bus halos geklaut das
ist das problem wenn du mourad medelci
okay aber sie kommen aus italien
der haupt anbau ist ein indien die
sterne über sechseinhalb millionen
tonnen her überhaupt aus italien die
türkei erkennt er auch da ist ja note
genau mein mann macht auch ganz viel mit
kichererbsen hahaha im supermarkt
bekommt ihr es in dem regal
da gibt es so viele verschiedene regal
in die nationalitäten genau ich glaube
die türkischen regal ist drin obwohl es
aus italien kommt jetzt auch von dem
türkischen regal vom international reger
ich werde es jetzt mit joghurt servieren
und zwar essen wir das privat eigentlich
auch ganz gerne bei uns in der familie
gab es früher immer da gab es nudeln mit
joghurt als reis mit joghurt und ich
finde hier passt einfach perfekt dazu
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier nummer 500
gramm joghurt und zwar ist es ein stich
fester zehnprozentiger joghurt habe
nochmal eine knoblauchzehe und salz
pfeffer und minze also ich mag es nicht
wenn joghurt bei dem rezept muss man mit
dem bereich macht es weil man hat er
jetzt hier keine sauce mit dabei keine
nudelsuppe und das ganze noch mal
richtig gut auf nämlich die
knoblauchzehe und treibt damit rein
ich hab dem angriff seine handynummer
ein trick
kennt ihr die maßeinheit eigentlich den
gesprächen sei es gut verrührt und dann
kommt noch salz und pfeffer mit rein und
salze etwa einen teelöffel und mit
je nach geschmack
tsokos ist fertig du kannst du mal einen
teller hohl und des gerichts auch gleich
fertig ein teller bitte jetzt kann ich
direkt servieren
falls noch etwas flüssigkeit in der top
er im topf oder in der pfanne ist müssen
einfach den deckel auf machen und etwas
so kochen lassen dann verdunstet es
gleich und vergesst nicht den rosmarin
und da flogen raus zu nehmen
so hat der erste teller ist für dich
weißt du schon mal vor kosten wenn es
gut ist sich auf ok zu senken
kuchenteller aber du hast nur gesagt hey
du musst schon konkret und dann kommt da
etwas joghurt als ich gebe jetzt joghurt
mit drauf es muss auf jeden fall mit
drauf damals auf wen er macht so bis auf
die sich auf die seite würde ich mitten
drauf hauen mit ich abgesagt
und dann kommen noch ein paar
frühlingszwiebeln mit drauf freuen sich
die arbeitsgruppe morgen richtig und
etwas pfeffer
das ganze hat jetzt wirklich nicht
länger als eine viertelstunde gedauert
klasse obwohl du hast es hat war ich
glaube gemacht das stimmt bisschen
länger als gedacht
vielleicht
also ich mag es sehr gerne ich habe eben
weil es schon probiert und murat macht
auch mit joghurt sehe ich gerade häufig
schon einschlägig ein eiswürfel mit rein
naja falls ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt geht auf einem blog auf celis -
blog.de da steht noch mal alles ganz
genau
ihr könnt mir auch gerne schreiben weil
sie das rezept etwas an abwandeln
möchtet aber ich finde so wirklich
richtig genial fall mit diesem lang hat
weil sie sehr aromatisch schmeckt und
die die gewürze passende ein bisschen
soll damit dazu zählt eben auch sein
letzter vielzahl ich weiß noch wie ich
wissen muss hier bitteschön noch mittels
dann bist du wirklich gut gewürzten
ansonsten schmeckt etwas fahrt sehr gut
doch überhaupt also qualitätsurteil
möglichst super-jackpot nie also viel
spaß beim nachkochen und bis zum
nächsten mal wenigstens wissen andere
richtung
da ist nicht die freezers soße auf trend
ist schon knapp drin und das fleisch und
die die penne und der joghurt schmeckt
auch nicht schlecht
jetzt habe ich noch den ultimativen
serviert tipp für euch und zwar schmeckt
es ist gericht so ja schon wirklich
richtig gut aber perfekt schmeckt wenn
er noch eine limette nehmt bei der man
die schale mit verzehren kann deshalb
eine u bahn sollte oder eine bio limette
man gibt einfach noch ein bisschen den
betten schale darüber nur darauf achten
dass ihr nur das grün verwendeten nicht
des weißes schmeckt etwas bitter und
dann habt ihr das perfekte gericht hat
von abwarten können appetit